Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
We've got a lot of stuff to do, but now we finally have the tools to do it.
So I'm going to take some of these for the road
to munch on while I'm swimming the long way back.
Good thing I got an extra battery.
So I need to get over to the Aurora.
First, I got to make a pit stop at the life pod, which I can juuusssttt barely see in the distance over there!
Then, I need to build a base by the Aurora.
So I am all done here, I'm pretty sure I scanned everything that I need.
The only thing I don't have is marble-melon?
Uhh, but I think I'll be okay without the marble-melon.
DIVE! (5x)
Ow. My legs, and knees, and intestines.
So I'm going to make my way over to the, uh, life pod and then to the Aurora to build my base.
So, anyway, I'm going to do that now.
I'll be back in a bit. Love you! *blows a kiss*
Did my life pod drift back to the right place?
I think it did!
Good for you, Bubba.
You know where your home is.
Okay, God, I have another message.
I don't want to know!
I don't wanna know!
Here we go. *robotic voice says, "Playing message"*
Nine new biological subjects designated. Mode switch: hunting, analyzing. Sharing subject location with other agents.
*confused Mark* I DON'T KNOOOOOW WHAT ANY OF THAT MEANS!
I have no idea what you're talking about.
Buuuuut, I do know that I need to get what I need to get and then I need to get the frick outta HERE.
So what I'm going to do is... old?!
OLD?!
Old already?
So I only need one of these.
How can it be old? I literally just left the island!
Hopefully, I can still plant that and be able to make what I need to make.
I'm going to take more titanium.
What do I need to make a fabricator?
That's the most important thing: to make another fabricator when I get over there.
I need a wiring kit and I need a computer chip.
So, I can make those here, and THEN do what I need to do.
I need three silver oral-ore basically, and then I need to take that with me.
So, I need to take the titanium out of my GODDAMN BAG
AND PUT IT IN THE GODDAMN STORAGE
and get the silver, which is going to be in the uh... it's going to be in the uh... the thingamabobber.
You know? Down here, in the death forest!
The forest of death!
SILVER. Silver. SiLvEr. Silver. SILVER!
Haabuski!
Alright.
So, now that we got enough silver--I even got a little extra so that I will be able to do everything that I need
to do, uh, once I get there, and I need, uh, I would be able to build more stuff.
And I've got gold, which I'm pretty sure is supposed to be used for *uncertainty* power solar panels?
I have no idea, but, maybe, maybe somehow, I can hook my base up to the Aurora and use its radioactive core-
in some fashion to be able to, power my base?
I know that's totally logical. And yeah.
The thing is totally back to exactly where it was!
I'm just going to dump all this 'cause I need to get table coral.
CORAL!
Okay, got that.
Frrrrppoodeedododoldah!
Hurroopodee!
So, now I should be able to make what I need to maaaakkkeee!
And what I need to do--rotten?
Goddamn it, it's getting more and more rotten by the day.
So I don't have any titanium but, frankly-
no, I need titanium because there is no titanum over there.
So, I need to *breath in* to be (sing-songy) VERY STRATEGIC ABOUT WHAT I BRING.
This should be enough to get me started, and then everything else I-I need to get later.
So, I should have everything I need to get where I need to go.
*in a deep voice* That guy is standing in my way.
*determined* I won't let anything stand in my way! Habooskki! Jurrupudoo! Okay.
And we're off!
Squadala, we're off! (really, Mark?)
*ehh*-Squadala, we are herrre. (yech.)
We're not here. We are still on the way.
Alright! Okay. Hello, Aurora!
You're looking lovely.
What a big honkin' ship.
How did they shoot it down?
I mean, again, who is they, but how, how did they shoot it down?
What did they u-ohhhh!
Nice! Cool.
So this is always going to be marked off.
And it's going to be really annoying because if I pick this one up... the other one's going to be here.
So I'm going to have, like, this permanent glow.
Let me just drop off some of this titanium here so I can pick this thing up.
'Cause if the other thing--oh, good. The other one's not really there.
It's kind of there, I think it's still there, somewhere, but, thankfully, it's not forever there.
So, I've got this stuff on my lawn; let me just push this off.
Get off MY LAWN!
GET OFF MY LAWN.
Get off my LAWWNNN.
This is just a temporary base, so it's not going to be 100% permanent here.
But at least I'm going to start building.
Alright.
So, yaarr' going to be...
right, rit, righhhhht HERRRRE.
*smiles* Squadala! (plz no :( ) This is a good enough place as any.
Okay, so, we got that, we need the multi-purpose room-eh. My titanium! The one that I put under the--
Oh, if it's unreachable under there, I'm going to be so pissed.
Where did it GO?
Where did it GOOOOOOO?!
NO, you can't do this to me.
You can't do this to me! (it did)
I brought enough!
I BROUGHT *voice crack* ENOUGH!
Oh, no!
Ohh, no.
(exasperated) Where did it go?
Oh, dammit!
AH, dammit.
Okay, there's got to be... there's got to be titanium deposits around here somewhere.
There's just got to be.
I spy... with my little eye... some TITANIUM.
Boop.
Alright, now I got everything I need... well, I had everything I needed.
*sudden regret* NOOOO, I FORGOT, I DON'T HAVE GLASS!
Fuuuuuuccckkk, I can't build a GODDAMN HATCH.
Ahhhh, I'm a tit-monger.
Ughhh.
I am so dumb. I am so incredibly dumb.
I did not make any GODDAMN GLASS!
(cool yer' tits, Mark)
AHHHHH!
(YOU CAN MAKE MORE)
Do anger squats to appease-I-eesh...
When constructing larger habitats, it may be prudent to separate
work and leisure spaces in order to maximize productivity.
Treat this, as your home! Treat this space as your home but remember that it is not.
GET AWAY FROM MY HOME, YOU DICK.
I have to go get some GLASS.
Fffff-fricker dicker.
Alright, I'll be back, but I don't have anymore GODDAMN POWER.
*underwater noies* Oh, hello.
Well, that's weird.
There's that locker with the picture of the lady here.
Same locker that we've seen in a lot of places, but there's nothing down here.
*Karen warns Mark, "Emergency--"*
(oblivious) Luggage bag?
*10 seconds of oxygen--*
(still oblivious) What, luggage bag?
Luggage bag? I've never, ever seen a luggage bag before.
(realizes) Oh, God, 10 seconds.
Ahhh, shit. NOOO!
AHHH, NOOO!
NOOOO!
*Mark watches the blackened screen of death*
*SOUND OF DEATH*
OHHH, C'MON!
FUCK YOU, FUCK YOU!
FUCK YOU.
FUCKA YOU.
Where am I?
Where the heck am I?
God dammit.
AHH, FUCK.
Ah, I still got the luggage bag.
That's okay. Okay, so, I guess that was actually just a shortcut to get me back to the base sooner, but...
Okay, whatever.
I found a luggage bag. I have no idea what the luggage bag is.
Hang on, let's see about this.
Luggage bag.
What?
What??
Wha--
*genuinely confused*
What...WHAT?!
Really?
(enlightened) Oh.
It-ohh, it's a storage container I can place in-i-in my-in my  pla-place.
Ohh.
Okay, that's weird.
Okay, I'm going to make glass.
(plz do so)
I'm going to make a lot of glass.
Alright, so anyway, I'm headed back to the other base.
I've got glass to make a hatch to be able to get in there.
I've got enough to make a fabricator there, but I also need power; that is another thing that I need.
So, I won't be able to fabricate anything until I make solar panels, which need quartz and titanium, but-
that's fine, because I don't need to fabricate anything, so I can make those and then fabricate what I need.
So, I should have ABSOLUTELY everything I need minus the quartz, which I'm going to grab on the way there.
So, all that said and done, I am in relatively good shape and I'm not going to bitch and moan about anything anymore.
(you sure?)
Ever. (okay...)
Okay, hatch haaaaaaaiiiiiiiii- ooh, maybe I shouldn't put it here.
Ah, I'll fix it later if I do.
Alright. Aannnnd, I'm home!
*Karen informing Mark, "Emergency power only.*
*Oxygen production offline.*
It worrrkkkss, so I just need to make--I just need to get one more quartz, which is right here, oddly enough.
I need to get this one quartz, and then I need to ma--I'll make a solar panel and then I should be good to go-
for pretty much anything I need in terms of power production, because I'm pretty close to the surface,
which means I am going to get a lot of sun, so it should be pretty efficient.
Why can I not make- there we go.
Oh, c'mon.
(dammit, Mark)
Okay, so I need one more titanium before I do that.
Son of a biscuit.
C'mon.
Give me some goddamn titanium.
Where's all the limestone?
There we go.
*breaks limestone* Here we go! That's all I needed.
So, with this, I can now salvage the bigger pieces of metal that I got.
I can create a storage container.
I don't have the materials to do that, but, you know, I got the duffel bag! That's why I brought the luggage bag so I could store stuff.
Perfect.
Excellent.
And it'll make it a little homey!
Little touch of home.
Little touch of humanity in my place.
Which is good, 'cause I don't have any other human companions.
I am literally all alone here. *forced laughter*
Alright, and I fixed up the...the solar panel to look a little better, which is kind of nice.
Can I put it right there, right on the entrance? That'll be good...so I can stack 'em up a little better.
(singing up the scale) Hooooooooooohhhhhhyy!
Yay!
Okay, we got it.
Habooksi!
Alright, that's good.
Okay, so now we just need to maaake... the fabric- FUCK!
Ti-ta--
Fuckin' titanium!
(shit's sake :/ )
God dammit!
*silly* GAWD DAMMIT!
It's gonna be nighttime by the time I get all this shit done and I'm not going to be able to get any power!
FAACK.
I just need one more titanium. ONE.
ONE MORE, C'MON.
*Karen's ignored warning*
Are you kidding me, have I ever looked? I'm-I'm really scanning really hard into this frickin' chasm...
I can't see anymore goddamn limestone outcroppings.
There's gotta be one more. There's gotta be just one, sweet, delicious, more piece of gosh darn titanium.
HAAA! Trying to blend in, I see you.
Gimme. *bonk*
YES! YEEEESSS! Do I have what I need?
I have... one. Wait, no. I have one. I just have one?
*silent anger* What? Excuse me?
What the frick? I thought I had another one, but I guess I'm MISTAKEN.
God-dammit.
Maybe if I go somewhere else I could find some limestone bullshit because apparently it's not here.
God dammit, it really-it's going to be night by the time I find this son of a bitch.
I could've--
I could've swam all the way back-
*SEETHE*
-to my own life-pod,
grab the rest of my bullshit titanium,
*SEETHE*
'cuz I don't know why I decided that I needed to be sparse at THAT point in time,
but apparently, I'm a bargaining man.
'Parently, I'm an idiot. That what I...
Not seeing anything, yep, and here comes the NIGHT.
EEEX-CELLENT.
No titanium?
PERRR-FECT!
Exa-cuh-tal-lee what I wanted.
Exa-cuh-tal-lee what-
*saw a deposit*
Please be titaaa-ni-uuum!
*not titanium*
FUUUUCK YOUUUUUoooooo?!
*another deposit*
Come on, please. Please, baby.
*haha, no*
FUCK YOU!
Fuck you! Fuck you, 'n fuck all of you.
Not you guys. (thank jebus)
Fuck all these limestones. I see one more over there. Imma' get it.
Just as soon as I get some god-damn air!
*Rrrrrr*--everyone's angry for me. (no, we're dying)
I get it, I-I understand, and I appreciate the empathy. (okie-doke.)
This better have frickin' titanium in it.
This better.
This bitter-better-batter-better.
I gotta' get rid of my god-damn copper-kipper.
Swa-booski.
*THERE IS A GOD*
YEEEE-ES!
FFF-FINALLY!
*exasperated shout* Can't believe how hard that was!
(wait, hold on, what?)
Dick joke. (oh, jeez. -_-)
*sound of arousal?*
Okay, but we got what we needed; now I can make a fabricator.
And then finally, I can just pick up the scrap pieces, turn 'em into titanium!
This shouldn't have take so long!
*baby talk* I don't know why it did!
But it did, and I will...
*POWER FLOOF*
...I will survive.
I will survive!
I will persevere!
I will do whatever it takes to survive in the dark depths of the fuckin' ocea-aah-n.
Okay, alright. *Helen: "Welcome aboard, Captain."*
Bo-kay.
Here we go.
Shoop-yes.
My whoop. Yes.
Squoo-bi-doop!
Yeah, that was a little off from where I had it, but...
HAAAAA-booski!
I've got it. I've got it.
"Aerogel?" What the fuck is that?
*confused* What...?
Okay, anyway, we-we don't need to worry about that, because I need to grab one of those
titanium scrap pieces which should be...
...which WAS right in my lawn, but someone took it--there we go
that's what I needed right there--sandshark, get away!
I don't want you here!
But I got that. That's all I need for that.
Then I can put this in here--make it into titanium.
Four pieces of titanium!
*clap*
How hard was that?!
Why'd that have to be so hard?!
Okay, so we got that...
*...Detected.*
*mocking blubber noise*
*fish noises*
*his mind is weak*
Oh no, wait, I wanted to put the duffel bag down, for some reason. (you picked it up)
No, no no no, no no no.
No no. (yes.)
I need food, but I need to put the duffel bag...into slot 1, and put it...
...Riii-ght-right-right-right-right-right...
Right there.
*loving it*
Look at that!
*realization*
That doesn't do anything. That's a decoration piece.
Ah. That's not actual storage.
Eeeeeyyy, it's fuckin' bullshet.
*suddenly a goblin* Alright. Here we go.
Lemme' just make a llllll-locker.
No, I need to make a wall locker, because I need--
*he remembers*
That's right, I need to put the naaaa-mes!
Yes! Okay, so I gonna' do that, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna' put up a bit higher than I had them before.
*starts building* I like 'em up a bit higher.
Aaaaand habooski!
Okay. There we go.
*delighted shout*
The lockers are back! (hallelujah!)
*delighted cheering*
Okay, anyway, so I need to put this stuff away.
*notices forgotten fruit* That is super rotten!
Put the copper away, put the lead away, salt, glass, "that"!
Uh, this. Uhm...where did I get so much glass?
Did I make all that glass? (pretty sure you did)
Did I need to make all that glass? (probably not)
Flare! We got the re-breather I'm gonna' keep on me.
Rotten lantern fruit can go in there. (not the minerals)
Let's see if we can make a grow-bed...we don't have the titanium at the moment.
But that's because I put it away, maybe? Yes, I did.
Okay, so I'm gonna' try to make an interior grow-bed.
Put it riiii-ght...
Shoo-bi-di-shoo-bi-di-shoo-bi-di-shoo-bi-di-shoo-bi-di.
And can I put--okay, can I put the rotten thing in there and will it grow?...
...is the question.
Can I put the...rocket--
*plants fruit*
Yay?
*gasp* Is it gonna' grow?
Aaaaaaaah yeah, there it is! Yes!
We got food growin'!
*morale forever lifted* Yay!
*clap* Ohhh, this is a wonderful day!
Ohh, it's a wonderful day, and when that grows, it's gonna' be SO NICE
because it's gonna' grow full and big, big and full.
It's gonna' grow so nice, and we gonna' be able to--
*lantern delicacies*
--eat our own food.
But, right now, I actually don't have any food, and we're running... low on power 'cause it's currently night-time.
Oh man, that was a slog.
That was an adventure.
That was a waste of time. (whut.)
But that's okay, because that's all part of the experience! (damn straight)
So, before I end this episode here,
I am going to...try to get a bead--ooh.
Try to get a lock on materials, supplies, everything I need, and also source some food.
So, if any of you slowpokes want to...
be eaten by me, yep.
Apparently, they do.
So, I got some slowpokes here; hoverfish, peeper, and all that jazz.
That's good, because we can just eat those up.
Nyum-yum-yum!
And then I'm pretty close to the Aurora; I'm pretty close to where I need to go.
Wha-what I need for the Aurora, what I have been told
is the Repulsion Cannon and the Propulsion Cannon,
but the interesting thing is the schematics for those
are actually near the outside entrance of the Aurora.
So, I need that to be able to get into the Aurora
and then move shit around to get what I need to get.
And I'm willing to bet that the Exo-suit is in there, somewhere.
I don't know for certain, but I'm guessing.
So, with all that said and done,
I just need a little more materials, and then...
we'll be able to moooo-ve on.
Mmkay...
We've got materials; I'mma' make one more of these bad boys.
Uhh...stack 'em real nice and tight like that.
Ahh-boink.
I'm gonna' make a spot-light just so that I...
...can know where the frick my door is.
I'm gonna' put this heeeeeeere--there.
Okay, haaa-booski.
Okay, I know that's gonna' consume power,
but it's going to be useful for me finding this place in the darkness.
And, I've got two solar panels anyway, so it should be okay.
Ehh, consumes a lot of power, though. (yeah...)
*important choices being made*
Ehh, I'll deconstruct it if it's necessary.
So, I've got a grow-bed, a base.
I've got a fabricator. I've got a locker!
I've got a duffel bag.
I'm doing pretty good for myself!
And next up on the list is the Aurora itself,
which I'm going to tackle..very soon,
but now, officially, I have the lockers back, which means that I will be able put you guys' names on there. (sweet)
So, if you got any tips and tricks that you want me to do in the next episode
that might help me along, let me know in the comments below. (do it)
I have been reading, and I will continue to be reading,
so let me know and I may just put your name on the locker (an honor to be treasured)
So, thank you everybody so much for watching,
and as always, I will see you...
...in the next video.
Buh-bye! (gute nacht!)
*lucky titanium*